Bob jpeg thanks for being here it's
great to have you we appreciate it a
busy week appreciate you taking time to
come down to Laguna thanks for having me
beautiful setting uh obviously the first
question the thing everybody wants to
know
I think you've got the world premiere of
wakanda forever tonight so tell us the
plot of the movie and everything that
happens please I think that's what
everybody wants uh well I think that
would uh probably get me excommunicated
uh but let's just say this we're very
proud of that film
and I think it's going to be a real
crowd pleaser do you enjoy those
premieres that's one of the fun perks of
this job I would think well you know
I've been with Disney 30 years now and I
started off my first 19 years at the
movie studio and as such I've been to
quite a few premieres and you know uh
there's a there's a tendency as they
kind of come one after another after
another to think about oh gosh it's
another Premiere but each one is really
sort of the gestation of a bunch of
creative people's really hard work for
about five years and when you think of
it in that context it's like wow this is
a really special moment and it's nice to
see those things finally kind of come to
life and of course this one because of
uh Chadwick Boseman an unusually uh
appointed and meaningful honor yes I'm
sure there will be a lot of emotion
tonight
uh well that sounds uh exciting I know
people are looking forward to that one
um obviously I have a lot to ask about
Disney but I want to start really with
kind of a satellite question and then
we'll get into some specifics so as
Jason mentioned you've been in the job
about two and a half years you came in
really like a week or two before the
pandemic hit so quite a time to take
over
uh you've been pretty willing from the
start to uh aggressively rethink
strategy approach I think you've wanted
to tackle some sacred cows
uh that's obviously also generated some
headlines that we can talk about in
different ways but you're you've had
your contract extended for three years
uh this year and so I really want to ask
in the broadest sense possible you just
mentioned you've been at Disney a long
time what's your overall sense as you
change Disney as it evolves of whenever
you hand the keys over how's the world
changing what does Disney need to be
what what do you move what are you
evolving to meet in the world that you
see right right well you know our Legacy
is really important we're a company that
turns 100 years old
next year and there's very few companies
like the two of ours that can say that
they've been around for a hundred years
or more in fact the statistic that I
understand is that lesson one one
hundredth of a percent of companies can
say they've been around 100 years or
more
so that you're sort of in rarefied air
to be one of those companies but for us
there's a lot of things
that will be the same storytelling for
example the root and the Heart of the
Walt Disney Company is in storytelling
that will not change but there are other
things that we'll need to transform and
we'll need to evolve another strength we
have that won't change is Our Brands and
franchises Our Brands and franchises
really are the the pillars that keep our
company going but technology is evolving
and much like at least from a strategy
standpoint you know Walt really set the
world on fire with you know the
multi-plane camera and a lot of
technology to help tell stories we need
to do that as well and sometimes that
means that you've got to sort of be bold
and use new technologies for
storytelling and give your creative
people another dimension uh to paint if
you will and we want to go ahead and do
that but ultimately really what we're
after is to create those magical
memories that last lifetime
let's get into some of the specifics on
that then I think I think one of your
biggest projects right now is uh is is
beefing up the Disney Plus app making it
I've heard the term uh Lifestyle brand
app thrown around compared to just a
streaming app what does that mean what
do you want it to be
well
you know once upon a time you talked
about some of the transformation I've
done since I've gotten a job I think we
had more or less five operating Utes in
the company and I distilled it down into
two the physical world of our parks and
our cruises and things like that and
then the digital or media world that we
operate in and that's a direct
reflection of a couple things but maybe
most fundamentally it's a reflection
that if you're a fan of Disney you
really don't care about our
organizational structure and the less
silos that we have excuse me the less
silos that we have the less times that
we have to worry about going
cross-transom in order to you know make
something happen if you look at the our
company Through The Eyes look at our
Brands our franchises our stories
Through The Eyes of a consumer all they
see is what I call Capital D they only
see Disney and we should facilitate that
so A Lifestyle brand is you know if you
look at what we're doing with story
living by Disney our 55 plus communities
it's really about embracing that
lifestyle not relying on the consumer
only to
sit together themselves but really
creating that that that
sort of that Lifestyle brand that Disney
is we just don't facilitate it so if
you've got the parks and the cruises and
the content doesn't mean you know
bringing Commerce we've talked a lot
about Commerce at this conference a
Commerce into it in a way more than
you've got or or other kinds of features
and things that you'd like over time to
see that grow and expand into
it's Commerce but I think the Commerce
is an outcome
of the inputs and the inputs are really
a holistic relationship with the company
so no matter what phase of life you're
in you're still building those magical
memories either for your grandkids or
for you or your friends and family and
so bringing together the physicality of
Disney plus the media element of Disney
into one element I think is really what
it's our job so one of the things you
talked about how the world has changed
even while Disney stays the same when I
hear that I think you know competitively
you're thinking about Amazon or maybe
about some Chinese apps is it is it
something like Amazon Amazon Prime kind
of thing product in a way as you think
about it no it's really not really it's
it's about customizing and personalizing
our products and experiences to cater to
what individuals want as opposed to sort
of looking at them in mass and trying to
program that way and I think when we do
that and we have a unique ability to do
that not only because we have the
physical and the digital or and the
media but because people have such a
deep founded relationship with Disney I
mean they love this company and and they
and frankly they don't even look at it
as a company they look at it as uh uh uh
a a utility they look at it as something
that's part of their lives part of their
identity yeah part of their identity and
you know that's great we need to embrace
that but it also puts extra pressure on
us because they don't think of us as a
company when we do things that normal
companies might do you know sometimes it
creates a friction because all of a
sudden they're like well well why are
you doing that but of course we have
shareholders that have different
expectations so one of the pleasures of
my job is trying to balance all the
different constituencies and uh
especially with the brand like Disney
well I I want to come back to some of
those points of friction but you know I
it's an interesting thing that you're
saying because as streaming services uh
have taken off we've all got a lot of
them part of what you describe I think
is it's fair to say is a way to make
sure Disney isn't affected by churn and
streaming but Disney plus is more than
just streaming
uh but the landscape has changed very
fast in the last couple of years so how
many streaming services between Netflix
and Disney plus and HBO Max and
Paramount how many can the consumer
ultimately want or pay for in your view
as this as this industry develops yeah I
don't know that there's an easy answer
to how many but I'll say
first I think we'll be one of them at
the end of the day and I think that not
everybody who's out in the marketplace
today will make it ultimately unless
there's some type of recombination of
you know secondary players in the
marketplace that combine to create
something greater this is a critical
mass business
streaming is a critical mass business
scale is really really important in
order to be able to thrive and so I
think there'll be fewer than more but
definitely we'll we'll be there and I
think you you kind of said earlier
more than content streaming other
feature Services other things are really
going to become necessary to make it in
this world absolutely part of the
Lifestyle brand is using Disney plus not
as a movie server
service
but using it as a platform for
experiential Disney uh engagement and so
uh we have ambition to use Disney plus
Way Beyond just a movie service
you mentioned a minute ago and I just
want to take you back quickly to your
restructuring of the company
I think it's fair to say Disney uh has
been famous for a long time for having
large very powerful fiefdoms as a
company a mixed history uh in different
ways with technology
can you just talk a little bit more
about how
you're thinking about the change in the
company and how it will continue to
evolve and and how much patience it's
going to require to get it where you
think it needs to be uh structurally I
mean the part of it is that digital is
so demanding in a sort of centrality of
many kinds of things in a way that
wasn't always the case so you've got a
centrality issue and you still want
local local work by artists so so
how far do you have to go still and
where you want the company to be well I
think if we follow the consumer we're
going to be in pretty good shape there
are certain things that the consumer our
guests our audience loves about Disney
and those things are immutable and will
never change call it the magic call it
Wonder call it fantasy call it optimism
those things can never change but I
think the challenge with becoming a
company that's going to turn to its Next
Century is not being so beholden to
Legacy that you're afraid to evolve
because we all know what happens when
you're afraid to evolve and so it's
again it's another balancing factor
between being respectful of the Legacy
understanding what got us here but then
knowing that the world is changing so
fast now and that we've got to change
with it I always say I'd like to be on
the front end of the wave not on the
back end of the wave and you know create
those opportunities create those
transformative moments for the company
and be bold and Technology he's
certainly a way to do that but I think
what what in the end of the day if we
follow the consumer we're going to be
great and to go to your question about
local markets versus you know obviously
Star Wars and Marvel and Pixar and
Disney those are big across the world
but in a lot of markets that is not the
predominance of media consumption and so
we've just built another thing that we
did that was transformative at least for
the Walt Disney Company we built centers
of creative Excellence around the globe
so that if there's particular content
that needs to be built in India that
caters to the Indian out audience we've
got that now and uh how many people have
you got around the globe and those
centers roughly do you know that's a
that's a big deal
we have roughly 200 000 cast members as
we call them around the globe a good
chunk of them uh catering to local
market needs so I I like to use the term
strategically consistent and tactically
Divergent because we need to be
strategically consistent across the
globe because we are Disney and Our
Brands and our franchises are everything
but at the same time one size does not
fit all so for instance in India they're
making Indian market content and for for
for for Disney there we might not see
that here ever
you would likely not see it here
although one of our goals is to have our
content travel so that we can build
something say in Latin America or Europe
or in Asia and have it be something that
is just pure great content and can
travel but we realize the majority of
it's probably going to stay within the
market that it was created in so that
that sort of touches on a larger thing
that I know has been an issue for you uh
in the job you've talked a lot about you
were just talking about scale a few
minutes ago I think you like to talk
about feeding the Beast the demanding
content to keep a streaming service
alive uh it's widely thought you know
and I think you've spoken at different
times that
Disney could have a deeper Content
Library over time would like to have one
your critics say you're very dependent
on the franchises and the extensions
how deep does your content pool need to
get do you think from where it is now
well
when you have a streaming service that
has the risk of churn
you need to constantly refresh your
services with new content so then it
becomes a question of rate what is the
rate of replenishment that you need in
order not to churn people out and
obviously we head coveted like every
other company had and essentially we
stopped creating new things for way too
long
things were in development because it
didn't take production so you can do
development from your homes but then
finally the dam broke and now all that
content is rushing out and so it gives
us the opportunity now to feed each of
our distribution entities whether it's
theatrical whether it's linear
television and streaming without having
to do what we did in the very beginning
which was select and choose a one piece
of contents coming out because it was
close to post-production when covet has
where is it going to go now we can
actually very thoughtfully plan the
amount of content we need to maximize
each Channel without being inefficient
by over producing and so you can imagine
nothing nothing nothing
the Dam breaks everything comes and
we're now just normalizing this and I
think we've said in the past that the
fourth quarter of this year is where
we'll finally reach some level of
normalization and and going forward uh
you know do things on a very rational
standpoint in terms of new content for
each Channel I know you're in a quiet
period so this is not meant to be a
leading question specifically related to
that but as you deepen your pool is it I
mean you have as you just said been been
creating a lot more and thinking about
that will it be all self-generated might
you be in the market possibly for
Content libraries if they become
available one day or other or or other
ways of of deepening the pool how do you
think about that in the space we have
the best creative teams in the breast
Best Brands and franchises in the world
and uh we're quite happy with our
ability to have an output level uh with
the kind of quality that we expect
across our distribution channels and all
countries without having to be a buyer
in the Open Marketplace so our plan is
to have all of our content creation
self-contained okay interesting
now you have an interesting uh piece of
it which is the Hulu piece
um and so you know Disney uh got some
attention with something like Pam and
Tommy
uh last year on Hulu
um how do you think as you extend the
content and the kinds of content that
fit with the Disney brand or don't how
do you think about that line of
appropriateness I mean I kind of assume
Maybe I'm Wrong I kind of assumed Dahmer
wouldn't be on the Disney or squid games
but uh you know Pam and Tommy did raise
a few eyebrows so so how do you think
about you know what's the line for
Disney in a changing World I'll withhold
judgment on any one title but what I
will tell you is every day even after 30
years I am amazed at the elasticity of
the Disney brand
I always say that one
our fans and our audiences
put their kids to bed at night after
watching Pinocchio or Dumbo or Little
Mermaid
they're probably not going to tune into
another animated movie they they want
something for them and I
again I want to respect Legacy I want to
respect what this brand is
but at the same time I know that we may
be even more precious about what's
Disney than the Consumer base is and if
it's if the consumer base has more
elasticity than we've traditionally had
in terms of defining what's Disney then
we probably ought to listen to our
audience which means we have more
degrees of freedom than we've probably
thought well it's interesting you you
say it it's interesting that you
mentioned Pinocchio though because
obviously one of the things we see
in our you know volatile in some ways
divided World Is is Disney often becomes
a political football partly because
people feel so passionately about Disney
and this so I know you want to reflect
changes reach all families all kinds of
families be contemporary but you also
get low back I mean light year was
banned in the Middle East because of a
same-sex kiss you mentioned Pinocchio if
I may be wrong but I think the new
Pinocchio
uh he doesn't change in the end he just
accepts himself for who he is so the
ending has changed a little bit with
sort of contemporary mores and you know
your your people love to get out there
and say Disney's too woke Disney's
become too correct politically correct
you know are they right do they have a
point what's your take on that those
criticisms and reaching that wide span
of people
you know I think the more complex
something is the more you have to really
drill down into the basics and we want
our content to reflect the rich diverse
world that we live in
and again I guess that's another way of
saying catering to your to your audience
but the world is a rich diverse place
and we want our content to reflect that
and we're so blessed to have the
greatest content creators and they see
it similarly but I think that's good
from a commercial standpoint as well
because then
you appeal to the largest possible
audience and certainly you know we live
in a world now where everything seems to
you know be polarized but uh I think we
want Disney to stand for bringing people
together I always say when someone walks
down Main Street and you look at the
castle you're not thinking you know I'm
on one side of the political Spectrum or
the other you have a shared belief in
all the wonderful aspects of what Disney
is and we want to use Disney to bring
people together and I think we'll do
that by diverse stories and diverse
characters what do you think your your
role as CEO of this gigantic company is
very specifically on that storytelling
front though I mean you you again I
don't you've gotta when you read oh
light year is banned in this region
because of this kiss or something like
that
I'm sure it comes to you after the the
product has been pretty far down the
path do you have a role in some ways of
shepherding shaping do you have views
about what you should be doing there do
you think you leave it to the creators
and and do you get to express your
opinions yeah we talk about shaping our
content a lot and some of the push-pull
of all these different forces but in the
end we have to follow our North Star
which again is storytelling and
catering to the audiences that are
that actually love Disney and all
audiences that love Disney so to be
clear you don't think Disney's too woke
uh I think Disney is a company that has
survived for a hundred years by catering
to its audience and it's going to thrive
the next hundred years by catering to
its audience
part of the audience uh sports fans I
think you affirmed fairly recently
um
uh ESPN remains important to Disney you
just signed a contract with F1 which I
think has been very good to Disney
there's a lot happening in the space
around live sports Amazon has been
chasing uh as a pro football are you
where you want to be on live sports are
you feeling like others in the space
there's more to get and uh and uh and
put on air and how are you thinking
about it we love live sports because
it's live sports and news are one of the
few businesses where there's a
timeliness to the viewing now and if
you're in an ad business that is
extremely important as advertisers try
to generate an audience during a
specific time we happen to be
very present and very proud of our work
in both of those areas I think for those
folks that look at ESPN and you know are
sort of
talking about well is it really right at
Disney is it not right at Disney I think
what they're failing to see is that ESPN
is a power brand
it represents like Disney does in terms
of its family audiences to the sports
fan it is the power brand out there and
that power brand while certainly it
plays a lot in the world of linear
television we talk about well you know
what's happening to you know the Cable
Bundle and our people core cutting that
is a particular execution of that brand
that happens to have been very powerful
and relevant for many years still is in
many ways but that is not the essence of
the brand the brand is much larger than
that and the brand will continue to
evolve in terms of how it reaches its
consumer but it's still a really great
brand and that's what we look at when we
look at the long-term prognosis for an
asset within the company or a brand or a
franchise within the company it's a
great brand and I know for a fact there
are dozens of companies that would love
to have that asset if they could
how do you know that
well you know there has been a lot
written in the Press about you know
ESPN's not a great fit for Disney
Disney's not a great fit for ESPN and
while we discounted it a lot of people
consume that and our phone started
ringing so we must have something great
with ESPN because everybody seems to
want it is is the brand flexible enough
to bring sports betting into it as
sports betting becomes more common and
popular around uh well once again that
will be up to the consumers and the
consumers particularly the younger under
35 consumers are telling us that they
want a robust Lean Forward Sports
Experience not maybe you know their
grandfathers Lean Back type Sports
Experience and so we're looking at all
different options in terms of how we can
deliver on that guest and consumer
expectation of a lean forward Sports
Experience
okay uh we've got to hit on a couple of
other areas of the time we've got left
and uh we could talk on time so I I
again thank you for being here
uh you came up and uh I know the parks
very well we and others have been
writing about the pricing strategies
you've taken uh you've candidly said
it's partly about managing supply and
demand because the demand is so high
with with high demand for the parks
you know does that suggest there's room
to grow the parks open more parks that
the parks business will continue to
change and again taking a Long View
uh where does Parks need to go for for
you
well our Parks were very successful
before the pandemic as you know we shut
them down depending on what park and
what part of the world for a year to two
years and we open them up and you know
uh we were very pleased with consumers
willingness to come back I think a lot
of that had to do with trust that they
had in our brand that we would open them
up in a responsible way and we certainly
you know through things like the NBA
bubble I think that was a model for how
you can actually operate a business
where people had to come together and I
think that brought us brought us a lot
of
a a lot of confidence in people's mind
uh since then uh you know we've we've
seen you know a strong business for us
and I think that as long as we continue
to have those stories and tell those
stories in a way that meet our guest
needs that will continue then to
encourage people to come to our our
parks and go on our cruises and continue
to be a robust business going forward do
you worry I mean you you mentioned the
the passionate Disney fan base it is
passionate they go online they have
forums they debate your pricing some
love it some hate it
what's the line on continuing to manage
it as you have but not alienating those
customers those diehards we want to
guarantee a great guest experience no
matter when people come if they come the
second Tuesday in September we want them
to have a great guest experience maybe
that wouldn't be so hard in the past but
if they come the day after Thanksgiving
we also want to guarantee that they're
going to have a great experience the
people who actually come into the park
that day we want them to have a great
experience so that no matter what day
you come you are guaranteed to get that
magical experience that creates magical
memories that last a lifetime
in a world where we don't control demand
you're left with one of two situations
you either let way too many people into
the park where they don't have a great
experience or you manage it by just
turning people away at the gate now
imagine if you're a family from Seattle
and you come to Disneyland
you come for a two or three day stay
you're there at 10 o'clock in the
morning and you're turned away
because we won't let too many people in
the park so what we developed during the
covid shutdown is a reservation system
so we can plan like every other business
out there like an airline that's got
fixed capacity like an airline Hotel
Cruise industry we developed a
reservation system so people would know
ahead of time whether they were going to
get in or not and then
we practiced yield management which
again which every other company in the
world can do so that we you know have
pricing be a reflection of how many
people we could actually let in and
still guarantee that great experience so
for some of our fans that's heresy you
know but I think it's it's not only good
business practice in terms of maximizing
shareholder value but more importantly
it protects the guest experience so that
when you get into the park you can have
confidence it's not going to be
overcrowded
we've talked at this conference quite a
bit I won't surprise you about the
metaverse I that's not a term you like
very much right so you know yeah we tend
not to use that word uh because for us
that's a big broad term well but for us
it's next Generation storytelling that's
all right so the parks I mean when you
think about the metaverse of all the
things it means the parks you can
imagine pretty quickly
that being a place for the metaverse
whatever you call it could really
enhance the the experiences that you're
doing the kinds of things you're
offering so how you and I have talked a
little bit about this how will the
metaverse change the Mickey verse
well it's for us it's the physical and
digital
aspects of your Disney lifestyle coming
together so that if you're on Disney
plus we should be aware assuming you
give us the permission to have that
awareness we should be aware of what
happened what you experienced what you
liked the last time you visited a park
and vice versa when you're in a park we
should know what your viewing habits are
on Disney plus again assuming that you
give us the permission and the ability
to use that data in that way but once
that happens we've now brought your
entire Disney existence into a place
where we can give you a better
experience in the park because we know
what your preferences are in terms of
viewing and a better experience on
Disney plus because we know what your
affinities are and what you're behaving
more tailored more I guess customizing
personalized things like that yes
customize and personalize for you people
that look like you for you how far down
that road are you really now is that a
vision more than a than
we're putting the arms and legs on it
right now inside our own uh technical
groups what we're trying to do is build
a toolbox of utilities
that then can be used by our creators at
Pixar at Disney at Marvel at Lucas that
can then take those utilities and use
them to tell stories in a different more
customized more personalized way given
your affinities can you give me I mean
it's hypothetical well maybe can you
give me an example of what you mean like
if I'm a Pirates of the Caribbean viewer
or Rider it extends like what what would
actually happen how are you extended
around theoretically okay so if let's
let's start say you were a Pirates of
the Caribbean writer yeah okay when you
go home
we know that you wrote Pirates of the
Caribbean so maybe the first thing that
get that pops up isn't other things that
you've looked at in the past or people
that look like you have seen in the past
but what you get is special programming
tailored to Pirates of the Caribbean
that would be unique to people like you
that is personalized towards your
preferences so because right now right
if you're on streaming service what you
get is well you've watched things that
sort of look like this or people that
are kind of liking your same demographic
what people would watch next and
oftentimes they're a complete record
scratch because it doesn't it it's
nothing like what you watch well if
people love Pirates then there's demand
for more Pirates so let's give them
something specific to Pirates it sounds
like your vision includes ultimately
even ways to potentially customize some
content for me and have there be a
feedback loop that takes it further as I
want to go exactly
I want to end on a couple of uh other
notes you know we're a few months out
from the controversy in Florida I don't
think we need to relitigate all the
details but given a little time and
distance when you look back on what
happened with the governor and uh
uh and the the tax uh benefits for
Disney you know what do you think you
did right and what do you think he did
wrong what are the lessons you've drawn
from that I think the lesson is the
lesson that we probably always knew
which is at Disney it's all about the
cast
if you think about the nature of why
people have great Disney memories
remember the M benefit is memories
magical memories that last a lifetime
the reason they have those yeah it's
about the castle and yeah it's about the
great attractions or they really enjoyed
that churro on Main Street but really
what they remember more than anything is
gas guest cast interactions and so if
that's the secret sauce for making those
magical memories when I ran parks for
gosh I don't know what it was like seven
years almost I would say 99 of the
letters I got were about guest cast
interactions not about attractions
literally it was almost every single one
so if that's the key to a great guest
experience and we're all about the guest
in the audience and maximizing their
experience then
you have to make sure that
the cast is at the center of everything
that you do so so
reading between the lines
you misjudged how the employees would
react with your initial out of the gate
and you had to
get that right because you need because
that was a challenge for you the
reaction to your original stance of not
speaking out on on the bill is that
what I would say is that we were
reminded through our The Passion of our
cast reaction and how important their
sentiments are on these issues in terms
of making them feel that they were
part of the Walt Disney Company could
relate to the products
that the Walt Disney Company puts out I
mean it's a tricky situation I mean
every CEO is grappling with it I'm sure
you get calls for advice because
it's a political world so Disney
probably more than most you get
pressures from Liberal politicians
conservative politicians workforces are
more active and vocal I mean it seemed
like your original aim was
to address that by saying we're not
going to get political and you've got
whether you wanted to or not you got
pulled into it so in a way it's an
object lesson of the challenge at this
time so uh for and not just for you but
for all CEOs so so people call you and
they say you know give me advice Bob
what do you what do you tell them stick
to your values stick to your North Star
simplify the cacophony of voices out
there and do what you think is right
you know one thing that was uh occurred
to me as I was was was getting ready for
this too is you know part of this
particularly in Florida
people were very personal with you it
got very personal for some people it is
very personal it's a reminder of the
of the importance as you said of Disney
in people's lives
when you've got this job did you were
you ready for that well like like is the
intensity of personal feelings people
bring to the CEO of Disney what you
expected it is it a surprise well I ran
parks for seven years and you know I was
quite familiar with how passionate
people can be I mean if we move a Cheryl
car 10 feet
it's a big deal if we change you know an
attraction
you know from Tower of Terror to
Guardians of the Galaxy you know while
the lines went from 30 minutes long to
six hours but they would come after your
predecessor in many cases for that not
for you personally when fans were upset
right I mean you're the guy on the hot
seat now is it is it hard
well certainly you know we all want to
make everybody happy all the time
I'm not sure that's possible in this
world so again we have to sort of
distill this down and say who do we want
to be who do we want the company to be
and by the way who I I my own personal
feelings aren't really important
what's important is how people think
about our company and so I take myself
out of it and I think that's that's sort
of the surprises everybody sort of wants
to be loved and everybody wants everyone
to like them and but in this in this
world that's not always necessary so I
wash all that away say what do we want
the capital D Disney company to stand
for and if we're doing right by the
capital D Disney company and can can
sort of sleep at night then you know I
can I can be Teflon and know that we're
doing the right thing but I do have to
finish by saying you did grow this beard
not too long ago uh was that was that
your idea was that the com staff idea to
soften it off this was my wife's idea
every time I escape for a week and go
have some fun uh I typically don't shave
and every time I come home my wife's
like don't shave it don't shave it so my
wife being the boss of the household uh
supported by my daughters who also
wanted me not to shave it it became a
thing so it's still here so that's the
most important customer on a good note
the most important thing is my wife okay
Bob jpeg thank you very much for being
here today we really appreciate it